A protein I use or gave plant protein. Could this be my tumor? Yes, it could. So this
person has a pancreatic tumor that does feed off of animal proteins, but any
protein could feed the tumor. So, so there's a question really and why is why would
you want to take protein? Why do you want to take a protein powder? If the person, if a
person is just constantly fatigued, their energy just isn't the pits, they are taking
five, six naps a day. They just can't seem to do anything. They have no drive in life.
That can be a protein deficiency and that can be a reason why you may want to answer protein.
If a person, make sure you don't make a mistake that I am losing weight, so I need to eat protein.
Eating protein is not going to help a person from losing with a weight loss issue. Protein does
not make you gain weight, kind of a hydrangea, make you gain weight. So, for a cancer patient to feel
like they need to be taking a protein powder, I question that. But the right protein powder to take
if you're going to, would be a plant-based protein. So, but the question is why are you taking it?
So, if it is like your fatigue is so bad and you feel like you have lost muscle mass and you just
don't have any energy and drive and life them by all means you can take that that would be the right
type of protein to take as a plant-based protein. But if you're not having those issues, I would just
drop that.